casino
[Music]
all right the year 2020 will forever be
known as the covid induced pandemic year
where sports was sacked for months
all sports came to a screeching halt the
unexpected pit stop left sports fans
empty and yearning for more in its
return
and it did return we say good riddance
to 2020 but before we do we came up with
our own roster of las vegas
top 10 sports stories of 2020.
there always seems to be a las vegas
connection to every major event and
coming up with our top 10 we found a
pretty diverse list
we start with number 10 and count down
to number one at number 10
prep sports cancelled the impact was
huge more than 16 thousand roster spots
in las vegas alone were left empty
no football basketball baseball or any
other sport as the state
canceled spring fall and winter high
school sports which also affected the
recruiting of hundreds of kids who hope
to catch the eye of some college or
university program
at number nine combat sports in the
bubble ufc was the first to bring back
its sport president dana white held 30
fights at the ufc apex
while top rank hosted 25 boxing cards
nine of those world title fights
including the 2020 fight of the year
number eight was the announcement that a
6 000 seat arena will be funded and is
being built in henderson
the ahl club will be home to the
henderson silver knights who reveal
their brand
virtually the henderson city arena is
going to rival t-mobile
at number seven prior to the pandemic
unlv rolled into san diego state and
pulled off one of the great road upset
wins in school history when they slam
number four the aztecs who were the last
unbeatens in college basketball in 2020.
an undefeated season great win we move
on to number six
las vegas kurt busch after 22 races on
his home track
finally reaches the winner's circle he
captures the checkered flag
at the las vegas motor speedway without
fans but not without fanfare this is
what
kids dream of when they grow up racing
you dream of
winning at your hometown track as we
roll into number five at number five the
huge virus victory causing las vegas to
miss on millions in economic benefits
when the shoot shut on the nfr also the
nfl announcing the grand nfl draft party
scheduled for las vegas will be put on
hold for two years and the pbr
which held its world finals in las vegas
moved to texas because nevada state
leaders wouldn't even take a phone call
and i don't know if our plan has been
reviewed in detail by anybody at the
state level
number four takes us back to hockey
where the vegas golden knights play
through all sorts of craziness in the
bubble in edmonton and they reach the
western conference finals for the second
time in three years
at number three the ace is making our
city proud as the lady aces are the
number one seed
reaching the wnba finals for the first
time they eventually fall to seattle but
ace's forward asia wilson earns the
league's top honor as she is crowd the
wnba's most
valuable player we feel
we've underperformed a little bit coming
in at number two
the vegas golden knights just two years
after reaching the stanley cup finals
fire head coach gerard gallot shocking
everybody in the city
the stunning news giving fans their
first indication that major sports is
certainly a business
and not only firing gallant but the
knights hire the enemy you know for that
clown to say that in the paper yet peter
deboer sheds the clown
outfit and is hired to take over head
coaching responsibilities in vegas
and our number one story in this covid
crazy year no surprise
after nearly five years in the making
nfl football kicks off in las vegas
congratulations
to the las vegas raiders the raiders are
playing in a two billion dollar stadium
and who
knows someday in the near future our
number one story could be that las vegas
is hosting a super bowl because that
future number one story doesn't happen
if 2020's top story got sacked
and i hope the people in oakland get
some pleasure out of the raiders winning
here
tonight happy new year
to everybody in las vegas and here's to
a healthy and happy 2021.
can't wait to meet some of you people
and
god bless you all